[Applause]
you look beautiful thanks gosh you look
beautiful ha I don't know where that's
coming from I'm shedding hung over you
congratulations so you're welcome yes
congratulations oh wait so you you are
just in Kansas City right I W I'm what
are you doing in Kansas City we were
actually Jason you know Mr sedus uh
called me in and said would I come down
to Kansas City his hometown yeah and be
part of thundergong which raises funds
for the steps of Faith foundation for
single and double amputees who can't
afford any Healthcare themselves and we
raised
$800,000 oh my god
oh that's so lovely yeah yeah and I hear
that you flew in last minute too you
were in Singapore I was in Singapore
were you doing in Singapore I wasting I
know mental yeah I was hosting the uh
environmental Awards the Earth shop
prize for a little known man called
Prince William never heard of him no
yeah yeah so yeah it's been a little bit
I have no idea where any of of my
molecules are at the they're just all
over the seat 3A from an airplane you've
met King Charles as well right I think
we have a photo because I want to talk
about this smirk real quick wait there
we go what what's what's behind that
that SM okay so he sidled up to me and
looked at my heels and went oh I didn't
realize we were address I shouldn't do
an impression of the king sorry sir he
he was like oh you know I didn't realize
we were dressing up and I said well you
did get the memo your highness but you
chose to just wear your
flats and that's a you issue it was so
yeah yeah that's not my problem that you
didn't dress up oh my God but you're you
are like tall in general I love when
women that are tall wear heels because
I'm short and I wish I had height but I
hate it because I have tall friends
that'll sometimes not wear heels because
they feel like I don't want to like
about the heels I love it have you
always been that confident yeah if
you're you know I'm 5' 11 in my stocking
feet and I I just think if I'm going to
go in on a heel I'm not going to do an
apologetic kitten yeah no I'm going to
be offensive yeah offive I'm go Wonder
Woman did your I I heard that your dad
actually taught you to stick up for
yourself right yeah my dad I mean
considering he's a very kind of old
school traditional English gentleman
yeah one thing he had always said was
just like oh my
daddy a beautiful you know he was uh
Roger body double back in the day are
you serious yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
oh my gosh he's a slick looking man he
is but he was always you don't look half
bad yourself there just saying like yeah
he um yeah he always had my back even
from when I was like 10 12 years old
when when his kind of dinosaur friends
would be kind of inappropriate and say
inappropriate things and I would shoot
straight back at them my dad would just
be like well you feel pretty stupid now
don't you to his friends oh my God I
love it and I think that's where how
inappropriate of
vile Pig vomits
very just calling them out I love it
yeah yeah and I've been like it all you
have to or they'll feel comfortable
doing that with everyone and not
everyone is as Brave or bold as that you
know what I'm saying not I think that
comes from having a dad that was just
like go on my go yeah yeah all right
well wait you shared you shared recently
that you're currently in a give no era
yeah here's here's my thing absolutely
zero I have been in that era
I feel like you and I Jor and I oh yeah
yeah we are fully as soon as you're just
fully bullied and you're like there is
no properly bull yes me too yes really
properly bulled like One Time by a very
tall girl she shall name name I can't
say it name remain nameless I can't say
it I have been drinking yeah no she like
pushed my head she just would literally
physically harm me at school and I was
little like I was like yeah so camera
are we on in your face who you are
yeah so yeah exactly
ex so did you get that cuz you're I
imagine you didn't cuz you're tall you
could have been like what you say got I
got it no cuz I wasn't I wasn't I was
quite
shy I I was too nobody believes me yeah
no I was I wasen to us we called
introverted extroverts that's what it is
it is actually yeah they used to tease
me about my height when they were all
you know much much smaller than me and
so likewise where's the camera in your
face look at me now yeah um okay wait
speaking okay I we speaking can I just
say you look so
hot don't you I love your new hair I
love your hair thank you thank you I
mean okay that is a good Segway now
thank you so speaking of hot you are
super hot and Hocus Pocus and here's the
thing I know it's the wrong season look
it's Christmas I'm like Back to the
Future right now but here's the thing
are I heard that there's a Hocus Pocus 3
happening and like maybe more of you in
it and I'm really excited about that I
mean I would be excited about that if I
knew anything about it oh well we heard
I would I would be there if I heard from
a liar I am going to be very upset
because I love that and I love the RO
you played at least another outing yes
you know there's so many ways you can go
with that and I just think her being
absolutely revolting but looking great
but doing it with such style yeah and
the whole I would have wanted to be a
child eaten by her yes exactly that's a
segue
there I hope so I loved it oh my God it
too fleeting I AB it I and I didn't
expect it that's what I loved about it I
was like is that Han I remember you I
freaked out I was like wait what is
there going to be a sequel I was anyway
this the wrong holiday I don't care it's
my show I will say what I want me and
girl that bullied me at school that was
to look at her Apple TV Plus holiday
special it's called Hannah wanham home
for Christmas I am so excited you well
done look at my boys being a load of
Christmas hams I love it but and also
one you sound incredible two you look
incredible like the whole thing is like
throwback is that the whole vibe that
was the vibe yes and and an Apple TV
were amazing we just like what do you
want it to be which is like pinch me
pinch me they usually have all the ideas
all the but they were they were
literally just like no what do you want
it to be and I was like I feel like I
want it to be an old school completely
Timeless like Dean Martin meets Carol
benette and you know you can sit there
with like your four-year-old
granddaughter or your 90-year-old
husband and all just it is a a
completely joyous musical
extravagant I love it I'm and it it
makes you so happy when you're doing
them they're my favorite things to do
anything dealing with Christmas but what
was like your favorite if you had to
pick a favorite performance uh um do you
know what probably not the one that
people would think it would be I have
two beloved friends called Scott Baker
and Patrick Davey and they are the
fabulous loung swingers in London okay
and they are two of my greatest loves
they are a gay couple that have been
together since they were 15 and I just
wanted it yeah and they've been married
for like 10 years and they're not known
they're not famous and they are my
daughters Godfathers and I wanted to you
know how I talk about you know keeping
the door open for other people I wanted
to go look guys look look at these
people I have and so we sing Have
Yourself a Merry Little Christmas and we
have Phil dster from Ted lasso joining
us on stage and it's the four of us and
it's literally like four Pals hanging
out now that's the best though because
then you feel like you're in someone's
living room you're like you get
something like almost like behind the
scenes I like that yeah take your shoes
off and just you know grab your eggnog
and just here's the spike it if you will
um no but here's the thing too is like
that's the time when I it always annoys
me because I we all do things in our
careers and there was like oh can you do
something more wellknown and I'm like
why don't we make this welln see I agree
see absolutely did you you shot it's a
beautiful theater you shot that in a
theater that's special to your Coliseum
yeah my mom was uh Meto soprano opera
singer yeah um at the London Coliseum in
the English national Opera mama oh my
gosh for 30 years there wow so you know
that building I know that building
literally like like a little kitty from
the age of eight until she retired when
I was 38 and I used to run around that
building talking to like the restroom
attendants and the canteen staff I
once in in the the orchestra behind the
orchestra pit there's like the store for
and I thought it was a very good idea to
go into it and someone shut the door you
mean like where it's like under the
stage like where they store stuff oh my
God I used to do that at my church sorry
Mom yeah it's not yeah yeah they used to
do that at our church we inquisitive
Minds all little curious so it was just
it was amazing to be back there and one
of the songs Oh Holy Night that I do um
I had the English national Opera chorus
you know that's their home and they
heard that I was doing a special there
and I had held out for that theater and
they heard and they offered to come and
sing with me and some of them are still
there from when my mom was there so it
was pretty what a f emotional yeah and
then you probably have your daughter
there my little girl so I was there from
the age of eight yeah and I put my
little girl who was eight when we shot
it in May no in the same box that I used
to always sit in box as in Theatrical
box not like a box I would make her do
exactly what I said in the
box so she was there she was there my
mom was there and I I dedicated the song
to to the two women in my life that is
so special beautiful like you're doing
something giving for other people but
what a full circle moment for yourself
is it hard to sing in front of your mom
since she's like singing is but well the
harder thing was and I know that you you
touch on it quite a lot you know the the
the struggle of Christmas as well
sometimes and and I make no bones about
it that my my beloved ma is sitting back
there heavily uh inflicted with
Parkinson's now and in a wheelchair and
I didn't know if her or my dad were
going to be there at all or even be
alive so it was a a really special
poignant moment and I I actually thought
I was going to struggle to sing but it
but it came out okay and you know i'
I've heard you highlight the fact of
people's loneliness at Christmas or or
finding it difficult and so I just
that's okay that's every Christmas in
yeah we're so similar like that of of
just showing there's the glossy gorgeous
side and then there's the the hard side
as well so I thought it was important to
to let people know while I was there
that that we don't all have everything
sorted out or how we would like it to be
but we all join together and and try and
make so powerful for you but
wow how powerful that domino effect is
for everyone watching it's going through
maybe something similar just having a
hard time like I think it's important to
say that everybody always thinks that I
like listening to Christmas music
because it cheers me up but I mean there
have been Christmases where I am like
crying and I'm like well this is not how
I expected my life to go you know and I
think that happens it's good that you
touched on that yeah yeah well we're
both single mamas it's a holidays this
can be a little it it here's the thing
it can be a little overwhelming just
because I I like to be super thoughtful
and that can be very overwhelming for
all the people in your life and your
kids and you want to make it magical but
I also find that it can be very special
because we have our own little things
that we do that nobody else gets in on
yeah we do it's a it's a very special
I'm hoping that when she gets older
whatever happens with me in my life
romantically I know that she will look
back on our years together and I always
say to her it's just us little chickens
yeah when when she looks back she'll go
that was the best of times just with my
mama a I love that well nothing to stand
for that that was perfect let's do
another commercial break everybody
Hannah winingham Home For Christmas Is
Now streaming on Apple TV
[Music]
[Applause]
Plus thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home